wait what
you know how much of our audience is
having the exact same reaction as you
I get what
wait what Hey listen sometimes you start
running out of ideas and Jubilee trying
to keep it fresh disclaimer we're gonna
be saying pause a lot this video
[Music]
these [__] said circumference
they said girth okay if they ask for
volunteers you already have to imagine
the people who are going to volunteer to
do this are going to have people who
have larger facets or people who think
they do no no no no no I think so
they're not Tuesday they're random I'm
checking out what you mean
girls [__]
hmm
shall We Carry On usually you do the
opposite after that I want to see some
big [__] after
true
you want me to do this the size of the
curtain I want to see the circumference
how much the Gucci wet with is really
Gucci wet yeah I want to see a whole
vibe with the the redness and the sugary
and taste the redness the wetness oh I
heard the redness I said damn are there
liquids down there I never heard us yeah
what this redness because I don't see
this I just didn't know it so is
everyone clear on what we're doing today
uh ranking disc sizes perfect I think we
all agreed all right
you have that look your eyes your eyes
man just something about them you look
like bro so I'm gonna say that you the
biggest all right now what we think is
what's the shoe size
I feel like you should slide down a
little bit guys it's not the shoes it's
not their shoes size eight is the size
of the kalishnikov
I will say I have seen some little like
smaller folks who are really packing so
I don't really don't know what to expect
though man but I think because y'all be
more bulkier I think y'all might be a
little bit more packing give me give me
give me a try give me a try give me a
try I thought he was I thought he meant
something else
give me a try that sounds like something
you tell him yeah
give me a try give me a try you go for
number three you go forward
[Music]
you go there all right how do you know
wait what makes you think it's like what
makes you think like what's your bottom
or where do you think you stand amongst
the group me yeah what do you think I
can't put myself though I said where do
you think you stand it's not up to me
it's up to you to decide I would say
y'all too at least in the middle cause
y'all a bit more happy I don't think I
belong at the other end though well damn
that's the point here I'll take one for
the team and go to this one so that no
one has to pick one what
yeah because I was thinking this name
was gay the whole time so what do you
mean
I mean whatever you think okay do you
have any input on this
I think I think I belong maybe in the
middle to be honest so I'm gonna slide
between maybe y'all I don't know this is
a smart black man
he understands the benefit of low
expectations yeah
I don't tell women I'm packing they
don't need to know because it'll just
ruin the surprise
yeah I mean like why would you roll up
in a [__] just hyping that [__]
up she already knows what to expect that
she gets there she's like oh it is what
it is versus just being modest about it
then she shows you about it Christmas
right like I feel like that's a much
better reaction just saying
[Music]
I feel like that's a bad placement I
don't think you should be at the at the
very end I'll just say uh I can uh suck
my own dick
speechless
foreign
this is a sickness of the highest order
this man has decided to be gay by
himself huh he has found a way to
sodomize himself and he enjoys it have
you ever seen a yoga instructor now
imagine him naked you're gonna imagine
him taking he has taken the cucumber and
inserted it deeper into his own mouth
before he does not approve of this
Behavior
I got one what's the longest
relationship everyone's been in for me
five years okay longest was like two and
a half all right mine was five years
what about you guys six years six years
five years not applicable
[Laughter]
it depends prepare depends if you ask
Camille you ask my partner
oh Jesse is messy
Mr Messy Jesse Jesse Messi as [__] okay
listen listen Jesse don't give up yo
look this means to go listen Leonel
Jesse is killing me okay you know what
this means I'll explain if you couldn't
understand basically you saying
she was in a relationship with me I was
in a relationship with the streets
this man went up to a lamp post they put
a ring on it you understand what I'm
trying to say [__] is the
streets is you know somebody's gonna
lock it down with somebody who's got
that consistent voice you know what I
mean Define boyfriend it's honestly
going to be on the smaller end
oh so because I've been in a
relationship for five years I got small
dick okay
no I don't know what this logic is but
that's what they mean it's actually the
opposite that's what they'd be trying to
say though that's actually the opposite
if you got quote unquote boyfriend dick
they trying to lock it down because they
want that [__] consistently and it ain't
because it's small it's because it's
good pause you're locking it in yeah
we're locking it in okay
any questions before we get started
I know not to do it yeah great all right
okay okay that's the Moment of Truth my
friend yeah all right
cousin gotta ask
imagine being a medical professional and
your only job is to gravitate measure
and be like pull out your dick I didn't
know y'all needed degrees for that
um
here's the thing
they got to measure itself right
how they gonna measure it's hard
we'll find out
[Music]
what if they're supposed to measure it
soft and you just hard the whole time
Hey listen what you want me to say man
these [__] is hot pause
bad feet so they just keep slapping the
thing come on death ah
did you find another dude popped a bunch
of Viagra yeah yo this is how I'll be
every day
[Music]
he said awesome
[Applause]
hey yo
hey yo you couldn't pay me enough money
to do this [__]
nah bro
what the [__] yo what happened there
girth
no I don't know bro sorry sorry this is
a weird one we're going to start with
the ranking for the soft length sizes
I'm not gonna lie this got to be the
most useless size to rank people by Soft
like the only time you care about this
you never care about it because it
doesn't matter
who would ever care about how it is when
it's soft like no one's like oh my God
you have such a large soft wiener like
what that's never happened
this is such a weird ranking
it's interesting because a lot of people
are going to see something soft and
they'd be like they're gonna think oh
yeah because my [__] is soft it's small
it doesn't mean anything so often you
know people dicks can expand I guess
but at the end of the day what a
revelation at the end of the day
no it's not very useful
seventh
Andy
sixth Asher number two
fifth Baron
[Music]
fourth Giovanni
third Tanner
we knew this was coming no no second
David yes
all right we're going to move on to what
we've all been waiting for the hard
length sizes in seven Andy in sixth
Baron all right
in fifth David I told you
hey pause but Asher's a grower hey he
might have started off on the smaller
side but he said [__] watch me expain
I start off the block at last but by the
50th meter yeah he's raining
fourth Asher you disappointed us
I really thought he was going to jump up
there like second in third Giovanni
second Tanner
and in first Jesse but we knew this yeah
you guys feel like talking about Psy so
openly has maybe really some pressure or
taboo surrounding the subject yeah
because it's dumb it's like just talking
about it it's like clearly no one
actually cares like I mean and if there
is any kind of actual care like it's
it's like we all know it doesn't matter
do the same video make it Anonymous okay
and show that nobody's going to be shown
the entire time you're going to see this
video is going to turn out very
differently yeah the kind of size
they're going to be reporting me very
differently and the experience of men on
the smaller end is going to be very
different like you have to understand
the selection bias that happens with a
video like this because if they're doing
this kind of casting call they say we
want to measure you and have you on
camera it's like if you're already
embarrassing machine you're not gonna
sign up to [__] do this thing you
know what I'm trying to say people who
are actually suffering from this are
never going to be willing to come up
here and talk about that openly or
they're going to be very less likely to
which is why everyone here represented
All Above average when it comes to this
high so it's just one of those things
where like that guy can say it one
because he's packing and he's doing
fantastic but for the dudes who are not
you got to think about what's their
mindset their experience yeah
I agree yeah so I don't know was this
really interesting
not really because I
if Jubilee does the female version of
this
then I'll be impressed but I'm about a
hundred bucks they're not gonna do if
they do you're giving them 100 bucks oh
yeah a jubilee can hit me up for a
collab I'll show up for free I'll fly
over there to their Studio sure yay Abba
versus uh the people who's criticized I
do believe I'll do it I thought you were
about to say Abba versus the boom boom
that's wild anyways
comment on Jubilee
excellent way don't [__] leave
hateful comments let's say yo yo you
believe you know what we want to see
women measuring they poops us yeah I
want to see the circumference of the of
the I want to see The Depths I want to
see the moistness I want to see the
volume the redness okay we want to see
all that we want to see the Gucci wet
wet we want to see how far they can
squirt across a room if prompted we want
to see everything
is that really necessary not necessary
but we want to see you
come on Jubilee